celebrity chef mario batali faces a
criminal charge for an alleged groping
incident two years ago vitaly is
scheduled to be arraigned in boston
tomorrow on a single count of indecent
assault and battery CTM investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is here with
more and a good morning
good morning this appears to be the
first criminal charge to come from a
series of sexual misconduct allegations
against Mario Batali according to a
civil complaint filed last summer the 58
year old chef allegedly assaulted a
woman in a Boston restaurant in 2017 now
the woman accused Batali of forcibly
kissing and groping her while taking us
selfie a lawyer from Batali says he
denies the allegations Vitali could face
two and a half years in jail if
convicted and would have to register as
a sex offender
in March Batali sold his stake in all of
his restaurants the first misconduct
accusations surfaced in 2017 at the time
Batali apologized and said he was taking
full responsibility for his behavior
following a 60 minutes report the NYPD
confirmed it was investigating
allegations that Batali drugged and
sexually assaulted a woman Batali denied
assaulting her and New York police
closed their investigations in January
without filing any charges Gale all
right Anna thank you